WHITE HOUSE BRIEFING ROOM,
THANK YOU.
MORE ON HERMAN CAIN’S LIFE AND
LEGACY IN THE SHOW.
A NEW DEVELOPMENT IN THE LEGAL
SAGA OF FORMER NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISOR MICHAEL FLYNN AND THE
HEADLINE HERE, IT’S NOT OVER
YET.
DOUG McKELWAY JOINING US LIVE
WITH THE DETAILS ON THIS.
>> GOOD EVENING, BRET,
GENERAL MICHAEL FLYNN FATE
REMAINS IN LIMBO WHILE THE BILLS
CONTINUE TO MOUNT.
TODAY, D.C. CIRCUIT COURT OF
APPEALS ANNOUNCED THE FULL COURT
WILL HEAR THE CASE OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE’S DECISION
TO DROP CHARGES AGAINST
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S FORMER
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR.
A THREE-JUDGE PANEL HAD EARLIER
UPHELD THE DOJ’S DECISION.
VEHEMENTLY OPPOSED TO
GENERAL BARR’S DECISION TO DROP
THE CHARGES AND HE INTERVIEWED
WHAT WAS THE COURT’S TERRITORY.
FLYNN DID NOT LIKE THE COURT HE
COULD SIMPLY FILE AN APPEAL.
TAKING ON A POLAR OPPOSITE VIEW,
ATTORNEY GENERAL BAR BELIEVE
THAT ED SULLIVAN WAS INTRUDING
INTO THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE’S
TERRITORY.
HERE HE IS.
>> THE ARGUMENT IS THAT IT’S
ALWAYS BEEN UNDERSTOOD THAT
DECISIONS, PURSUING A INDIVIDUAL
THROUGH THE PROSECUTION PROCESS
HOLDING THEM ACCOUNTABLE IS
INVESTED IN THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH.
NOT THE COURTS.
HE’S AN ESSENTIALLY IN OUR VIEW
OF SETTING UP AS A PROSECUTOR.
>> NOW A PANEL OF TEN OF THE 11
JUDGES WHO MAKE UP THE D.C.
CIRCUIT JUDGE WILL HEAR
ARGUMENTS ON AUGUST 11TH.
ONE OF THE 11, GREGORY, TRUMBULL
POINTE D HAS RECUSED HIMSELF
WHICH MEANS SEVEN JUDGES
APPOINTED BY DEMOCRATIC
PRESIDENTS AND THREE APPOINTED
BY REPUBLICANS TO DECIDE HIS
FATE.
IF THERE WERE TO BE A DECISION
SPLITS AND TIE, THIS ORDER WOULD
BE REMANDED BACK TO THE
THREE-JUDGE PANEL THAT DECIDED
TO CLEAR FLYNN OF THE CHARGES.